all right lisa schwartz and sandy's is
opening on a scale of one to extremely
shocked
how are you
feeling about how they pulled this off
oh no i knew it would always open i just
didn't know when and i'm really really
excited to actually be here and see it
come to fruition because that's what you
need to do and i think they probably
found it harder than they thought it
would be you know but listen hey we're
here and i'm celebrating it for them i
remember what it was like you know in
the early days when we were younger and
we started off you know we had something
like 37 places now so you know right at
the beginning it's challenging to get it
right
well you've obviously gotten it very
right and we know we're filming season
10 of vanderpump rules a decade of this
show well longer than that because we
skip one right so we're 11 years in
yeah how would you describe the vibe of
season 10 what's going to be different
this time around
well there are different issues i mean
there's much more mature issues and
we've seen you know marriages break up
we've seen you know people opening
businesses and i'm pleased to say that
we're not making the same show that we
were 10 years ago so there's a lot of
kind of evolution so to speak but you
know it's always been about a group of
people that are so inextricably entwined
and love each other but also so volatile
there's a lot of still
stuff brewing i mean that's you know
there's quick out the gate these guys
come right over will there be any new
faces joining are we sticking with the
people we were with season nine well i
love to have new people but it's kind of
hard to integrate new people as we've
seen unless you're kind of inextricably
entwined with somebody in a relationship
then it's hard to kind of get into this
group because a lot of these people
don't work for me anymore you know
i always have a lot of new people in my
restaurant for sure what about old faces
are we going to bring back anybody
you know what that's not my decision
honestly i like to see people grow from
their mistakes i've been very vocal
about this board but it was a sign of
the times and bravo felt they did what
they needed to do
but for me you know as you've seen my
job so much is to mentor young people
kick them in the ass and set them in the
right direction so i would have you know
appreciated kind of having you know had
the chance to do that really but
well i think one of the people you've
taken under your wing is garcelle's son
who's working for you in las vegas right
i mean
fans i think would die if you were to
ever film a cameo for housewives with
garcelle would you ever do that a
one-on-one scene with her oh well i love
garcelle i mean garcelle came to me when
we were having this fundraiser for haiti
she came to me and she said you know
could you give my son a job and to me
that's always something that i don't
want to hear i didn't know garcelle very
well and i said well what does he do do
we want to work in the restaurant
business so then i thought well where
does he live in vegas and i thought okay
that's easier for me because i'm not so
directly involved on a day-to-day basis
he's turned out to be a gift he's been
great and so i put him his face at my
restaurant you know of caesar's palace
and then he's moved to paris and he's
he's great
i like her very much uh you know i don't
watch the show anymore housewives but i
can imagine she's got a lot to deal with
if you know
does she give you any come to you for
any advice ever or do you not talk about
housewives at all she don't talk about
it i think it's kind of simpler that way
i don't want her to be in a position of
old lisa said this or you know so no we
actually don't talk about it but uh do a
cameo on that show i don't think so well
she said your name when she said that
oliver was coming to work for you and
the lady's reaction was gob smacked lisa
vanderpump
i haven't seen it i haven't seen the
show since i left but that's a good
thing for me yeah better at a distance
than in the mix yes yes i had nine and a
half years and a few of those years were
pretty tricky
you did you your name continues to pop
up though i don't know why i really
don't know why they don't just leave it
alone but apparently yes well the latest
was kind of this drama with pk and
dereed saying you did not reach out to
them and then you showed receipts to say
i did reach out to them in the wake of
the burglary has that been settled yet
or was what went down in the press what
went down in the press that was all that
happened look i'm not my memory's not
good enough to make up stories that's
why i could say look and they're saying
oh you photoshop this you go to his name
you go to the messages there it is what
more can i do you know i'm not into
making up anything as i say i'm super
busy with my dog foundation my
restaurants my new grandbaby you know
what i mean i i know it's just like it
is what it is okay but there were some
people that were quite good at makeup
stories on those shows have you seen
you